my kids keep thinking we've got all this
money that we can spend on them and I
feel so broke constantly even though
we're not really giving them money
they've got trust funds that my parents
set up for them when my parents passed
away and I just don't know what to do
anymore so Cheryl these trust fund kids
are hounding you for money yes and
you're but you're not giving it to them
I no but you feel bad because you're not
giving it to
them yes you have done the right thing
you have said no I'm not going to fund
this and that and I'm certainly not
going to do it at your whim if you feel
the need to be generous you can choose
when and how you'd like to be generous
for your family but they do not get to
treat you like Grandma ATM and come to
you whenever they feel like they need
this or that you're exactly right